but I want to talk about uh chat GPT
that's a good question I don't know
things are so unstable right now
changing so rapidly I I can't really
claim to see more than about six months
to a year ahead at most I mean not only
because things are so stable and strange
politically but there are things and
everyone on in the audience should know
this there are things coming down the
pipeline on the artificial intelligence
front that are just going to make your
hair stand on end within the next year
because there is so much transformation
going on in that domain and and that's
been the case particularly for the last
six months that it's almost unimaginable
you're going to see things you just
can't possibly it's smarter than you and
it's going to be a hell of a lot smarter
than you in two years so you can get
ready for that too so I'll tell you what
shout gbt is just so you know because
you need to know this and I don't know
what sort of technological Revolution
this is Gutenberg Press level it's
something like that this is a big deal
so this AI system to General language
processing model was released about a
week ago a week and a half ago and uh I
I went and interacted with it you can
it's an AI system artificial
intelligence system it basically is
trained on well a massive Corpus of
spoken and of text so it's derived its
models of the world from the analysis of
human speech essentially it isn't using
real world data yet but that will be
happening certainly within the next year
so and chat GPT analyzes a very large
Corpus of text and that Corpus is
growing all the time now it's already
sophisticated enough I went on to it
last week and I said okay some of you
know I've written these books 12 rules
for life and then beyond order 12 more
rules because you know you can't have
enough rules and I asked that this is
what I asked it to do I said write me an
essay that's a 13th rule for Beyond
order written in a style that combines
the k King James Bible with the doubting
that's a pretty difficult to pull off
you know any one of those things is hard
the intersection of all three that's
impossible well it wrote it in about
three seconds four pages long and it
isn't obvious to me for better or worse
that I would be able to tell that I
didn't write it and that's pretty
impressive although you know maybe not
its relationship to what I've written
but the fact that it could do that
grammatically perfectly right and quite
impressive philosophically I also had it
write an essay on the intersection
between the Taoist version of ethical
morality and the ethics that are
outlined in The Sermon on the Mount
which it just nailed got that dead right
brilliant again it took it about three
seconds there was a computer engineer
who purported to work for Tesla he asked
GPT child gbt said look I worked for
Elon Musk but I haven't been doing much
for the last week so I need you to write
me 10 bullet points about what I
probably would have done as a engineer
at Twitter what 10 things did I do last
week that were productive and valuable
and oh if you don't mind write me the
accompanying computer code that goes
with each project and it did that to
three seconds and the computer code
works that's already there so then a
university Professor did this he thought
oh that's interesting any student will
be able to write any essay on any topic
with chat gbt and uh someone gave it an
SAT by the way and it scored about as
well as the average student in a
well-functioning public university so
that's how smart it is so that's
basically an IQ test he said write me an
essay gave it a topic wrote yes he said
now grade it said if we can automate the
students we should be able to automate
the professors too and so it provided a
complete comprehensive analysis of its
own Essay with grade someone else asked
it write the screenplay and describe the
characters for the next 900 million
dollar Hollywood Blockbuster it's like
Bang plot characterizations then someone
else took the descriptions of the actors
and said generate computer
photorealistic computer images for each
actor and all the AR systems can do that
so I'm going to tell you what's going to
happen next this is going to happen this
year so get ready okay so now we have an
AI model that can extract a model of the
world from the entire Corpus of language
it's smarter than you and it's going to
be a hell of a lot smarter than you in
two years so you can get ready for that
too but it's not that smart yet because
it's just a Humanities professor at the
moment it doesn't test its linguistic
knowledge against the real world that's
what a scientist does right you come up
with a theory that's linguistically
predicated and then you throw it against
the world and see if it sticks and then
the world tells you whether or not your
linguistic construction is valid but the
new AI systems will be able to extract
out patterns from the world itself from
images and so forth and then be able to
test their linguistic constructions
against the world and so they'll
practice just like scientists and the
most advanced models are going to use
text and image and action as well
because they'll build a mortal Human
Action and all of that's going to come
down the pipes within the next year so
hang on to your hats ladies and
gentlemen because one of my friend
Jonathan pajo say Giants are going to
walk the earth once more and we're going
to live through that maybe
when you extrapolate when you look at
what this does and what it's capable of
and I think what scares people is
something that seems to be a person but
doesn't have any emotion doesn't have
any Soul it's not us but it behaves
exactly as us and then you can put it in
a physical entity so if you have this
chat GPT and then you extrapolate to
version five six seven eight nine ten
and then there's a physical thing that
has this ability inside of it to
communicate with you like ex machina
where it's exhibiting all of the
behavior characteristics of a person
like one of my favorite movies of all
time was when that guy who was brought
in to sort of run some tests on these
artificial intelligence creations and
determine whether or not they pass as
human and um he is in love with this
woman she's manipulated him to the point
where he's aided her in her escape and
then she leaves him in that room with
the bulletproof glass and he's pounding
on the glass and she walks away with not
a thought at all about him it is the
ultimate example of the worst case
scenario of where this can go where you
have something that behaves exactly like
a human being and knows how to play upon
your sexual urges your emotional desires
all of those different things that she
plays upon and then she just walks away
from him and leaves him to starved to
death in this bulletproof room you feel
bad for this woman who is uh contained
and you know when she sang to him when
the power goes out don't trust him and
then you know the power comes back on
she behaves normally again you're like
oh my God like she's trapped this poor
creature they've made an a person
essentially and she has these thoughts
and hopes and dreams just like a regular
person but now she's trapped and he
falls in love with her and even though
he's seen her in her robot form when she
puts skin on and when she puts clothes
on when she's in front of him he's in
love with her so anyways Elon Musk one
of the things he's working on see he he
thinks that the world would be
controlled by whoever produces the most
functional AI system the fastest because
there'll be a first mover advantage and
one of the things musk has been working
on for a long time are distributed AI
system so that you'll have your own
artificial intelligence to protect you
against well let's say against Google's
artificial intelligence for starters
yeah or or the ccp's artificial
intelligence because you can bet your
hat they're working on that about as
fast as they possibly can
[Music]